listen i'm going down the south beach
tonight told you about that right i
don't know you might have
baby what do you want to do you want to
have sex since we're going to bed yeah
i filed wow
yeah sure oh that's hot do what we want
oh this is unbelievable yeah i know it's
a little strange
yeah frank tomorrow morning you're gonna
go to the bank and draw one million
dollars out of your account and deposit
to account number eight
slow down
a million dollars it's just not gonna
happen what do you mean
should i get it jump me to get it maybe
she get it i'll get it i'm getting it
i'm afraid mr dawson isn't here right
now this melanie with the big
the woman want to hang up the phone
they think it's a game i'll call him we
need to make an impression
melanie is he upstairs
or did he leave the island
i'm willing to cooperate because i like
you and i don't want to end up in the
ocean again
keep out for divorce you tell him he's
never going to see his wife again he
doesn't want to see his wife again you
just saved him a hundred grand a year in
alimony are you gonna kill me
is there a problem
i am that hard you hope you didn't
you're a hunk but you are a piss-poor
extortionist if you don't let me
sing he's so dumb it's adorable
hey you keep your wife out here
someone's labeled a steeler you promise
you